In the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit, amen.
The reading from the Sinhaxadeon from May 25 on which we commemorate the third finding
of the head of the forerunner.
On the 25th of the month we celebrate the memory of the third finding of the venerable
head of the Holy and illustrious prophet and forerunner, John the Baptist.
The precious head of the forerunner, having once again been lost after its translation to
a messa, was found by a priest many years later in a silver vessel buried in the earth
in a consecrated site at Comanus in Cappadocia.
It was translated thence with great pomp to Constantinople, where the emperor and the
patriarch, surrounded by all the people, received it with devotion, and laid it in a holy place.
Through the prayers of our holy fathers, O Lord Jesus Christ our God, have mercy on us and
save us.